I make for you guys the big fat fatty
it's a 27 inch 13 pound sandwich and if
you can complete it and eat it in 40
minutes or less by yourself you get the
Samsung free and you get a new sandwich
on the menu made right now your part
we're gonna start off with a 27 inch
baguette I'm gonna hit it with some
garlic butter one two three four five
Tommy
[Music]
it's now time to make that that ribeye
into cheese we've gone to if that sounds
we do over the top about Warren food and
I had all these great creations I won
the big one that was so big so dope so
cool that almost no one on the earth
cannot eat it you know everything on
this grill looks absolutely delicious
but there's just so much of every single
one of these items confidence we put a
whole basket of french fries on it
tomatoes garlic onions seasoning this
Chili's me in-house with Black Angus and
jalapenos and dark chili powder and a
chili butter like we made all this we're
gonna finish the big fat fatty in grand
fashion right here Pat's house we're
gonna use our final condiment on this
thing it's called bad sauce oh my
goodness the big fat fatty boom oops so
big you can't even get a tooth
[Music]
I'm Sergio and this is the big special
family challenge my god when they
finally put it in front of me on the
table that said in that I am alone in
this I'm going for the meats first cuz I
figure I can get the carbs in later
we're at like the halfway point and I'm
nowhere near halfway done with this
sandwich I'm trying to focus on more
meat but I just can't stand the thought
of shoveling more cheesesteak into my
mouth so I try and just refocus on the
cheese sticks because at least they have
a different texture to it
so we got five minutes left by now the
restaurant is open other people are
coming in customers are coming in and
just wondering what the hell is this guy
doing at ten in the morning trying to
eat this big a sandwich a few guys
offered $500 of their own money if I
could just finish it at all I don't
think most of them even had the money I
think they just knew it was impossible
and then it kind of sets in with about
five seconds left I feel like I'm gonna
puke if I put any more food in my mouth
and it's just a struggle to just keep
down these three four hundred rings that
I just shoved into my mouth at the last
minute I feel very defeated right now
try my best and my best was nowhere near
good enough I learned how hard it is to
just constantly keep chewing forty
minutes is not that long when it comes
I gotta exercise my job on it
I'm ever gonna try one of these again
[Music]
you
[Music]